some people use the letters foil as a
strategy for making sure they have
multiplied all the terms use the foil
approach to multiply 3x plus 2 times 5x
minus 7
I'm actually not one of those people who
like to use the foil letters because
it's just kind of a form of memorization
as opposed to realizing that you're just
using the distributive property twice
but with that said let's actually use
foil so you see that it actually is the
same thing as using the distributive
property twice so just to remember foil
it literally stands for so fo I L the F
in foil stands for first first the O
stands for outside outside the I stands
for inside and the L stands for last so
not only do have to remember for you
have to remember what each of these what
each of these letters actually stand for
but let's see how that applies to this
to multiplying these two binomials so we
have we have 3x plus 2 times 5x minus 5x
minus 7 so we're starting with the first
we're starting with the F we have to
multiply the first terms in each of the
binomials so that's going to be 3x times
5x then we do the outside terms then we
do the outside terms so that's going to
be the 3x times the negative 7 so this
is going to be plus 3x times negative 7
then we want to do the inside terms then
we want to do I'll do that in green then
we want to do the inside term so that's
the 2 and the 5 X so that's plus 2 times
5x and then we want to do the last terms
and the last term's are the 2 and the
negative 7 so plus 2 times negative 7
and we end up getting 3x times 5x is 15
x squared + or I should say minus
because is going to be a negative sign
here so 3x times negative 7 is
negative 21x and then we have two times
5x is let me do that in that same shade
of green so this is plus 10x and then
two times negative 7 is negative 14 or
now it's minus 14 and we can add these
two middle terms together we can add
these two middle terms together if we
have negative 21 X and then we add 10 X
to that that gives us negative 11x so
this right here is negative 11x and then
these other terms over here we have 15 x
squared minus 11x minus 14 so we just
used foil what I want to do is show you
this is the same thing as applying the
distributive property twice so if we
have I'll rewrite the problem 3x plus 2
3x + 2 times 5x minus 7 what we can do
is distribute the 5x minus 7 we can
multiply that times the 3x and we can
also multiply that let me make it clear
when I say that I mean this whole 5x
minus 7 we can multiply it times the 3x
and by the 2 we're just distributing it
over the 3x plus 2 so we get literally
we get literally 3x times 5x minus 7 5x
minus 7 plus plus 2 times 5x minus 7 2
times 5x 5x minus 7 and then this gives
us this gives us 3x times 5x is going to
be 15 x squared 3x times negative 7 is
going to be negative 21 X negative 21x
and then remember this step we're just
applying the distributive property again
so then we have 2 times 5x is going to
be 10 X so plus 10 X and then we have 2
times negative 7 is negative 14 so we
actually got the exact same result that
we did when we applied foil when you
simplify it
you get you get this answer again